[Music]
flying through the night I wash over
this world a silent Guardian a watchful
protector a dark night I'm okay fine so
I'm not Batman I'm just a bat but like
Batman I'm often misunderstood people
think I'm scary strange and dangerous if
they only knew my story though I'd be
cheered as a hero when people think of
bats many think of vampires who want to
suck their blood but the truth is that
out of over 1200 bat species only three
are vampire bats out of these three only
one prefers the blood of mammals and
even these bats mostly feed on cattle
maybe that still doesn't seem so great
but vampire bats can be a great help to
humans a chemical known as des motor
plays found in vampire bat saliva helps
break down blood clots and is being
tested by recovering stroke victims of
the remaining thousand plus species of
bats about 70 percent feed on insects
these bats help control the real
vampires mosquitoes whose nasty bites
are not just annoying but spread
diseases like West Nile virus a single
little brown bat can eat a thousand
insects every hour and a colony of
Mexican free-tailed bats can eat several
tons of moths in just one night in the
United States alone bats provide an
estimated 3.7 billion dollars worth of
free pest control for farmers which
benefits everyone who eats the foods
that they grow fruit bats also called
mega bats because of their large size
are important for the role they play in
plant pollination by traveling between
flowers while feeding on nectar and
fruits these bats transport the pollen
and seeds that help plants reproduce in
Southeast Asia for example the cave
nectar bat is the only pollinator of the
durian fruit other bats pollinate
peaches bananas and the agave plants
that tequila is made from without them
many of our food plants would be unable
to produce the tasty fruits we enjoy as
heroes of the ecosystem bats have their
own unique
utility belts bats have been a source of
inspiration for the design of flying
robots and even an energy-efficient spy
plane as they are the only mammal
capable of true powered flight
echolocation a type of biological sonar
is also used by bats as a way to
navigate and find prey in the dark
although there's a common misconception
that bats are blind in truth all species
of bats have sight and some have even
adapted large eyes to see better in dim
lighting many people worry about getting
infected by bats and like any other
animals bats can carry diseases like
rabies in reality though less than half
of one percent of all bats carry this
virus that's about the same odds as
getting the same result on a coin flip
eight times in a row the perception that
bats are often diseased may come from
the fact that sick bats who may show
unusual behavior emerge during the
daytime or be unable to fly are more
likely to be encountered by people so a
good way to protect yourself is to
protect bats as well keeping them
healthy protecting their habitats and
reducing their risk of transmitting
disease in North America
bats are threatened by a devastating
sickness called white-nose syndrome this
fungal infection causes VATS to wake up
while hibernating during the winter
unable to find food they expend large
amounts of energy and eventually starve
to death
white-nose syndrome has wiped out entire
caves full of bats with a mortality rate
that can exceed 90% climate change and
habitat destruction also pose serious
threats to bat populations for example
in January 2014 a record heat wave in
Australia caused over a hundred thousand
to die from heat exhaustion some people
just want to watch the world burn and
that's all over the world are threatened
by damage to the places that we call
home including mangrove swamps
growth forests and of course Baptist so
even though I'm the hero of the story I
do need to be saved and now that you
know the true story about us bats you
can learn how to protect such heroic
animals install a properly designed bat
box one of the easiest ways to provide
shelter for bats discourage the use of
pesticides which can harm bats when we
try to feed on the insects you want to
get rid of in the first place avoid
going into caves where you might disturb
hibernating bats and always
decontaminate your gear after visiting a
cave if you have unwanted bats living in
an attic or barn contact your local
government to safely and humanely
relocate us and if you come across a bat
do not attempt to handle it but instead
call animal control
Batman might want to keep his identity
secret but a great way to help real bats
is by continuing to learn about them and
spreading the truth that they are real
heroes even if their good deeds are
often unseen
you
[Music]